le calme est revenu aux alentours du
pont aérien en partie effondrée alors
que les travaux de déblayage des
décombres ont permis d'extraire la rame
de métro accidenté l'enquêté se poursuit
pour comprendre les causes de la
tragédie
lundi soir l'effondrement de la
structure de 12 mètres d'eau faisait
plonger dans le vide plusieurs wagons
lors d'une conférence de presse le
président mexicain a promis des
investigations impartiales
il va y avoir une enquête approfondie
[Musique]
sans égards d'aucune sorte pour chercher
à connaître la vérité
l'enquète pour homicide involontaire a
été confiée au bureau du procureur de
mexico mais déjà de nombreuses critiques
vie celui qui était le maire de la ville
lors de l'inauguration de cette ligne en
octobre 2012
marcelo ebrard d' l'actuel ministre des
affaires étrangères et potentiel
candidat à la présidence mexicaine
dès sa mise en service une usure des
rails et des roues des trains de cette
ligne avait été détectée plusieurs
accidents se sont également produits
dernier en date en janvier dernier
lorsqu'un incendie avait endommagé les
installations de contrôle du réseau
l'accident avait fait un mort et 29
blessés pour ces manifestants la
corruption et la négligence des
politiques ont conduit à ces drames
certains ont perdu des bras des mains
des membres
c'est de la négligence et cela peut
arriver dans n'importe quel autre ligne
de métro
c'est à cause de la corruption de
l'impunité du manque de soins pour ceux
d'entre nous qui vivent habite et
transitent dans la banlieue justice pour
les familles en attendant les
conclusions de l'enquêté près de quatre
millions et demi de passagers vont
continuer d'emprunter quotidiennement le
métro de la capitale mexicaine le
gouvernement a décrété trois jours de
deuil national